hey youtubers this Charlie this week on
Walking Dead we learned that there is a
super flu going around Rick probably
isn't going to be a farmer anymore
someone's feeding the walkers and Carol
is hardcore so let's do a super quick
recap of the walkers shitstorm that went
down inside cellblock D and then talk
about what it means
don't you dare COFF on me so the episode
picks up with Walker Patrick walking
around cellblock D looking for a
late-night snack maybe a cuddle buddy he
ends up getting one of the woods burry
people and [ __ ] is on after it's all
over Lizzie and Micah's dad is getting
ready to turn Carol almost gets Lizzie
to end him but she can't quite do it in
suspending the rest of the episode
telling Lizzie that she's weak but maybe
she's not weak maybe she's just messed
up outside me Shawn ends up getting run
over with walkers and Carl ends up
shooting one with a shotgun
Rick ends up giving him the hat turns
out you're in the club after you kill
your first Walker at least it's his
first Walker as far as Rick knows
remember Rick has had a really strict no
gun policy for the last couple of
episodes so Carl using a shotgun is
actually a really big deal everyone
starts to realize that it's actually a
super flu that's going around a bug
they're not quite sure what it is but
they know that it turns people into
walkers overnight
remember on The Walking Dead everyone
kind of already has the Walker virus and
the flu just basically kills them
overnight turning them into walkers
overnight so it's basically like a
walker replicator so the threat level is
up to Big Time eventually outside Walker
start to crash the gate and they find a
bunch of dead rats lying around meaning
that someone has been feeding the
walkers causing the mass there Rick ends
up using the pigs to lead them off in
this really heartbreaking scene it's
almost like he's killing his children it
kind of looks like he's given up on
pacifism at this point he burns the
Pigpen then gives Karl his gun back and
puts his gun belt on with his giant gun
mean this is probably the end of farmer
Rick
long live farmer Rick so people that
were suspected of having the super flu
had been kore turned off and death row
but it turns out that someone had burned
the bodies someone had killed them
prematurely so that they wouldn't turn
high reasons up finding Karen and kind
of heartbroken starts to lose it and
that's where the episode ends so what
does this mean and who is responsible
for feeding the walkers and what's going
on with this superflous so number one
let's talk about the super flu first
Greg Nicotero on talking dead actually
talked a little bit about the flu he
said it was inspired by this historical
flu that basically just killed people
super fast
night so it sounds like the flu was
actually just a coincidence it sounds
like someone isn't actually poisoning
people using the water supply like a lot
of people suspected he was responding to
a fans question to when he said that
there will be way more walkers this
season than in any season previously
number two who burned those bodies at
the end who burned Karen and that other
person the other person that got burned
was that person from the first episode
who was skewering walkers remember the
really close-up shot of the one that
looked like it was infected it was
basically infected with that super flu
and the person that killed it was
actually that other person that got
burned remember Rick was the one with
that red gas can burning the pigsty
before that scene so it could have been
him or the other theory is is that it
could have been Carol because she is
basically one of the most hardcore
characters on the show now just trying
to teach the kids how to kill people in
number three who is feeding the walkers
greg benson actually also on that
episode of talking dead had this really
awesome theory that I kind of agree with
that it was actually Lizzie who had been
feeding the walkers and if it wasn't
Lizzie it was definitely one of the
other children remember that the
flashlight and this dead rat were
actually really high up that fence and
how else would those things have gotten
stuck up there if someone hadn't had
tried to climb up that fence and stick
them there while they were throwing rats
over so it was obviously a small person
using a ladder and remember in that
first episode Lizzie saw that person
with the name tag the Walker was the
name tag name Nick so she kind of
started to think of these walkers as
people so it's possible that she was
sympathizing them in this really twisted
way trying to help them out either way
it was definitely one of the children
remember they were all giving the
walkers names so next episode we got to
find out who burned those bodies stop
Tyreese from killing everyone trying to
find out who burned those bodies and we
got to deal with this superflous
personally I don't think it was Rick
yeah he's hardcore but he's still a
human being inside so I think Carol is a
much better suspect for that but let me
know what you think so I'll be posting
my next Walking Dead video next Sunday
after the episode airs after episode 3
years be sure to subscribe to get it
since there's no Sleepy Hollow tomorrow
- I'm also posting another game of
Thrones Season 4 video first or Davo
since you guys all requested him so much
if there's anything that you thought was
really important in this episode that I
didn't mention be sure to write it in
the comments we'll discuss a PHY and in
the meantime you can click here to watch
my review the trailer for the Doctor Who
50th anniversary episode that just
posted and you can click here to get all
my other Walking Dead videos now let's
all give each other a really sanitary
high-five make sure you wash your hands
before you give me this high-five don't
you
jerk off on me